quiero que me digan que ven aquí
basura
esa es la basura que en promedio genera
una familia al día en bogotá
yo también veía basura
pero desde hace unos años pude empezar a
ver oportunidades
nací en una familia típica bogotana
mi familia tenía una empresa
constructora entonces el sueño de todos
era estudiar una carrera a fin para
llevar el legado continuar el legado
casarse tener hijos un hogar y ser muy
felices
pero yo nunca supe no nunca entré en esa
es ideal de familia
sólo tenía dos intereses la música y la
naturaleza recuerde cuando era pequeña
me lo pasaba escuchando música mientras
mis primos jugaban y veían televisión
yo me sentaba frente al equipo de sonido
y escuchaba música y cantaba todo el día
en el colegio me metí en cuánta cosa
había ambiental entonces era el grupo
ecológico del club de apicultura y
estaba en todas las campañas para pedir
que no votaran basura en el recreo
porque ni siquiera hablábamos todavía en
ese momento de reciclaje recogía cuánto
perrito callejero me encontraba
abandonado y eso me generaba un montón
de problemas con mi mamá yo era algo así
como la oveja de colores de mi familia
pero toda esta sensibilidad me generaba
muchísimo dolor
porque no sabía qué hacer y cómo poder
aportar o cambiar las cosas entonces
empieza a sentir frustración y esa
frustración se convirtió en rabia
no podía entender cómo les estábamos
haciendo tanto daño a nuestra vida
porque el medio ambiente no es algo que
está afuera somos parte de él
entonces decidí hacer lo que hace la
mayoría de jóvenes cuando no saben qué
hacer y es que me convertí en una
rebelde sin causa
decidí desconectarme para dejar de
sufrir y sentir esa confusión y me fui
por el mundo de la rumba me puse a
consumir cosas le hice un montón de daño
a mi planeta
yo creo que recreando lo que no me gusta
del mundo
entonces
fue un momento muy duro en el que toqué
fondo
y cuando uno toca el fondo no queda otra
cosa que empezar a subir y empecé a
subir
empecé a encontrar mi lugar y entendí
que la única manera de cambiar el mundo
era cambiando a través de acciones
la vida me dio la oportunidad de
trabajar en un proyecto con niños y
niñas en un barrio del sur de bogotá en
condición de pobreza extrema
a mí eso me cambió la vida poder conocer
como realmente vive la mayoría de gente
en colombia es muy duro después de dos
años de estar dando clase de música a
través del juego empezaron a pedirme
instrumentos musicales
no había dinero para instrumentos
musicales porque un instrumento musical
es un lujo y si no hay ni siquiera lo
básico como la comida una vivienda digna
la educación la salud pues
esto era casi imposible entonces
volvieron estos sentimientos de
indignación que tanto nos la pasamos
sintiendo
pero ya no estaba yo sola había veinte
hojitas de colores
qué se podía hacer su momento feliz del
día
entonces tenía dos opciones o me quedaba
indignada triste llorar
voy a correr coherente con mi despertar
y buscaba soluciones
yo siempre me bajaba en un paradero en
ese barrio donde me recibía una montaña
de basura
solo fue después de esa conversación que
tuve con los niños cuando ya no vi
basura sucia y empecé a ver objetos como
tapas para los hoyas
y recordé un show muy reconocido que
conocí unos años antes en donde hacían
música increíble con balones con llaves
con de todo yo me imagino que lo conocen
y ahí encontré mi oportunidad
hice un show con los niños hicimos un
montaje super bonito y nos fuimos de
gira por bogotá y fuimos muy felices
luego me encontré otros chicos que ya
estaban experimentando con esto y conocí
a algo llamado la luthería urbana
la luthería para quienes no saben que es
esta palabra es el arte de fabricar
instrumentos musicales la luthería
urbana
es un movimiento cultural mundial que
cada día tiene más fuerza donde
decidimos tomar estos objetos en desuso
residuos que después se convierten en
basura para crear instrumentos musicales
profesionales
ya me imagino lo que deben estar
pensando
pero no
es algo más como esto
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
gracias estos instrumentos musicales
están construidos con basura este es un
ukelele que se llama el porno porno fono
que representa el poder del perdón muy
importante para el mundo
es una caja de chocolates esta es basura
importada de europa era chocolate suizo
esto es un palito que me encontré en la
calle se pulió tiene un micrófono que es
el parlante un despertador un tejido de
cassette para los que aún saben que es
un cassette y bolsas de papitas y aquí
machito hizo en un segundo en mientras
estuvo hablando un trueno con una lata y
un resorte
y gerardo hizo esta flauta pvc con un pc
y un corcho de vino que suena así
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
llevamos 8 años llevando este mensaje
este eco de la basura por todo colombia
por todos los rincones enseñándole a la
gente que la basura es nuestra
herramienta de acción y la música es
nuestro canal de comunicación porque el
problemas de información la gente no
sabe lo que estamos haciendo y las
posibilidades que tenemos también para
cambiar las cosas hemos sido desde la
guajira hasta lugares recónditos como
gilgal en el urabá antioqueño
hemos estado en solano caquetá hemos
estado hasta en el amazonas y en
ciudades tan importantes como bueno
también hemos estado aquí en san josé
del guaviare y en ciudades tan
importantes como parís
de gira con esta basura por europa nos
fuimos también
porque es una realidad estamos en un
momento crítico de emergencia en este
planeta
dicen que para llegar en el año 2030 va
a haber más basura posiblemente que
peces en el mar el primer objeto
plástico que creó el ser humano está aún
aquí en la tierra con nosotros no se ha
habido degradado el primero en bogotá
hacemos 6 mil 300 toneladas de basura
al día esto equivale a una torre
colpatria imagínense esto multiplicado
en dos días sería la torre eiffel
del tamaño porque es el doble de la
torre colpatria
qué vamos a hacer con tanta basura miren
en el mar como estas islas de basura ya
hay una que tiene
el tamaño de españa francia y alemania
juntas que está en el océano pacífico
pero hay una personita muy importante
y que está haciendo algo por este mundo
que es una niña que todos deben conocer
que estuvo en estos días dando
muchísimas horas con un cartelito viendo
los viernes hacer huelga frente al
parlamento sueco
ella dice que no puede haber zonas
grises que ya llegó el momento y es
ahora y no podemos probar el futuro a
los jóvenes
greta tumbes una heroína total y una
niña que está haciendo lo que no están
haciendo los gobiernos ni los
empresarios ni nadie por ellos es que
estamos haciendo esto y hacemos parte de
un gran movimiento mundial gigante que
decidió cambiar su consumo responsable
crear empresas países enteros donde
decidimos aplicar las 3r es como suecia
que reciclan 99% de la basura pitalito
huila
que también recicla el 40% de sus
residuos orgánicos
hay un pueblito que hace poquito que
dicen que es el
en la ciudad mundial del postre en
boyacá
que dejó de usar cupones para tener
otros empaques y entregar el postre para
que ese vídeo de grado
yo sé que ustedes quieren saber que
podemos hacer todos porque empresa no
solo los gobiernos y los empresarios
todos tenemos que hacer algo y toca
hacerlo ya me imagino que recuerdan las
tres erres
pero el orden real de las tres erres son
reducir primero luego reutilizar y de
último si tenemos que reciclar pero ya
en este momento las tres erres no son
suficientes
este gran movimiento consciente de
empresarios de personas y familias
enteras decidimos ir mucho más allá
aplicamos siete erres y les voy a contar
cuáles son la primera reflexionar de
dónde viene y para dónde van las cosas
no quiere decir que nosotros sacamos la
basura y mágicamente se desaparece
porque se la lleva el cambio
rechazar tenemos que rechazar lo que no
viene de buenas prácticas ambientales o
no se recicla nosotros tenemos el poder
de obligar a los empresarios y a los
diseñadores a que empiecen a crear cosas
que de verdad puedan aportar ya hoy a
este cambio no podemos seguir creando
empaques del empaque el empaque y
nosotros podemos no consumirlos
les toca cambiar sus prácticas tenemos
el poder reducir
porque necesitamos tantas cosas
realmente las necesitamos
ir en decrecimiento mejor
reparar si se nos dañó el celular el
computador la ropa podemos más bien
repararlo y no comprarnos el último
celular que salió y también rotarlo en
nuestras familias hacer que fluyan las
cosas
bueno ahí faltaron dos importantísimas
reciclar que separar en la fuente
que no es
digamos es un proceso que se hace
realmente la palabra reciclar es un
proceso que se hace a la materia prima y
lo hacen empresarios pero si nosotros
nos separamos en la fuente eso no sirve
de nada y la gente siempre tiene la
excusa es que yo no recibe porque el
camión revuelve la basura hace cuánto
existen los recicladores solo tenemos
que ir a hablar con un reciclador
preguntarle qué se está reciclando y
entregarle todo el limpio seco podemos
tener mil excusas pero pues depende de
nosotros siempre y la última regresar a
la tierra
esa casi nadie la hace que es compostar
lo que sale los residuos que salen de
nuestra cocina si eso va al relleno
sanitario genera muchísimos problemas de
la capa de ozono cuando se mezcla mal en
cambio cuando uno composta en la casa se
vuelve tierra nutrientes ya existen un
resto de personas que le llevan a uno su
compost era súper diseñada y bonita que
le luce bonita a la cocina con toda la
materia para uno hacerla pues digamos
revolver todo lo que tanque revolver no
huele no sale en moscos y en un
apartamento de 20 metros cuadrados puede
compostar y nutrir la tierra
los quiero invitar a mi casa
esta es mi casa junto con mi familia
decidimos aplicar las siete erres a
nuestra vida ser consecuentes es una
casa construida en barro embarek y lo
sacamos en una obra de construcción de
por ahí la 93 nos donaron eso lo botan
el barro bogotá
pues nosotros llevamos una volqueta
hicimos esta casa en pared que
reciclamos puertas ventanas pisos de
obras de construcción y de gente que
remodeló su casa
en el piso la placa tenemos 30 llantas
que encontramos por bogotá para fundir
la placa encima entonces nos ahorramos
un montón de plata en residuo y pues
además es de mediante problema que son
las llantas bueno todo el tiempo que por
todos lados es gravísimo y pues todos
los edificios deberían tener debajo
llantas
los muebles de la casa los hicimos y
como la decoración con botellas de vino
con rines de bicicleta
huacales de fruta tablas viejas de cada
más festivas y hasta sembramos nuestra
comida
también tenemos un baño seco para el que
quiero investigar que es un baño seco
compostar lo que sale del baño sin
contaminar el agua uno de las cosas más
locas que hemos hecho los seres humanos
contaminamos el agua limpia cuando todo
eso puede ser nutrientes para la tierra
la vida es un eco
pensamos y creamos lo que damos regresa
y que lo que sembramos cosechados
nosotros decidimos cambiar y crear
acciones reales cotidianas con la basura
como nuestra materia prima y mucha
conciencia para poder vivir en este
mundo cada día más sostenibles
hagan parte de este rebaño y pintemos el
mundo de colores muchas gracias
[Aplausos]